county school district board of trustees
met for the first time today
following a chaotic ending to last
week's meeting
about the superintendent's actions and
possibly terminating him
kristen drummond shows us how they want
to improve their communication during
the work session
i think that this is where the work
starts ccsd board of trustees
acknowledged division among the group
we even used to like each other
and we've got to come back to something
like that trustees recognizing the
concerns
and approved to formally create an
ethics guideline the decision follows
members reviewing the current board
members principles of
operation we just changed board
to a lower case trustee garvey leading
the group through modifications
additions and changes to the language
the board voting to take certain
sections out
and use as a framework for a separate
code of conduct type
document the current policies will stay
until that happens
following the october work session which
we believe
at such time we will be
putting into place a new document
of principles trustees also approve
finding a firm to help improve their
leadership
and provide training on balanced
governance an approach to avoid
micromanaging the superintendent as well
as district staff
and instead focus on monitoring student
outcomes
trustees add that consultants must also
guide trustees through the evaluation of
the superintendent
i think we definitely need a third party
to help us do this so that we can all
you know be valid and be able to
evaluate properly
trustees say they ultimately want to
improve their communication
and work better together moving forward
kristen drummond 8 news now
trustee daniel ford amended language in
the request for qualification she wants
the consultant to observe at least
two board meetings she says that may
allow the firm to watch more
in case a couple are the wrong meetings
in her words